♪♪
♪ YOU THOUGHT YOU
COULD FIX IT
BY YOURSELF ♪
♪ PLUMBING'S JUST AS EASY
AS BUILDING A SHELF ♪
♪ YOUR DIY BECOMES OMG
YOU'RE IN OVER YOUR HEAD ♪
>>> WELL, HELLO.
I'M GUS VANZANT.
AND WELCOME TO "IN OVER YOUR
HEAD" WHERE WE TALK TO FOLKS WHO
GOT A LITTLE OVERCONFIDENT
TAKING ON PROJECTS AROUND THE
HOUSE.
SPONSORED BY THUMB ICE.
DID YOU WHACK YOUR THUMB WITH A
HAMMER LIKE A CARTOON IDIOT?
NUMB THE PAIN WITH THUMB ICE.
OUR FIRST GUEST IS TOMMY DORIAN,
WHO SAID HE TRIED TO INSTALL HIS
OWN POOL.
UH-OH.
COME ON IN, TOMMY.
♪♪
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, LOOKS LIKE YOUR HAIR'S
STILL A LITTLE WET FROM THE POOL
THERE, TOMMY.
>> NO, THAT'S UNRELATED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OKAY.
SO TELL US, WHAT WAS BEHIND YOUR
THINKING BEHIND BUILDING YOUR
OWN POOL?
>> WELL, MY NEIGHBOR PUT ONE IN.
HIRED A WHOLE CREW AND AN
ARCHITECT.
THE WHOLE NINE YARDS.
I THOUGHT, IT'S BASICALLY A HOLE
PLUS A HOSE.
WHY OVERTHINK IT?
>> UH-HUH.
AND WHEN DID THINGS GO WRONG?
>> ALMOST IMMEDIATELY, GUS.
MY PROBLEM STARTED WHEN I TRIED
TO POUR THE CONCRETE WHILE I WAS
STILL DIGGING, TO SAVE TIME.
>> OH, WOW.
>> OH WOW IS RIGHT.
CUT TO, I'M UP TO MY WAIST IN
HARD CONCRETE SCREAMING, "HELP!
SOMEONE TURN OFF THE HOSE!"
>> SO YOU WERE ALREADY RUNNING
THE HOSE?
>> TO FILL THE POOL, TO SAVE
TIME, YES.
HAD TO HAVE IT OPEN FOR NEW
YEAR'S.
>> WELL, LOOKING BACK, ANY
REGRETS?
>> I DO WISH I HADN'T PUNCTURED
MY SEPTIC TANK.
THAT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT KIND OF
POOL.
>> THANKS FOR COMING, TOMMY.
>> THANKS FOR ALLOWING ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> ALL RIGHT.
OUR NEXT GUEST THOUGHT THAT HE
SHOULD, QUOTE, DO HIS OWN
ELECTRICAL.
PLEASE WELCOME FELIX CREWE!
♪♪
>> HEY GUS.
LONG TIME, FIRST TIME.
>> YOU MEAN, LONG TIME WATCH,
FIRST-TIME GUEST?
>> NO.
FIRST TIME ELECTROCUTED.
LONG TIME IT HURT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SO, HOW DID YOU DECIDE TO DO
YOUR OWN ELECTRICAL WORK?
>> WELL, I KEEP TELLING MY WIFE,
IT'S JUST WIRES.
BABE, IT'S JUST WIRES.
HONEY, NOTHING'S GOING TO
HAPPEN, IT'S WIRES.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU KNOW WHEN YOU SEE A GUY
DEFUSING BOMBS IN THE MOVIES YOU
THINK, I COULD DO THAT?
>> I'VE NEVER THOUGHT THAT.
>> WELL, I HAVE A LOT.
SO I THOUGHT, "WHAT THE HELL,
I'M GOING TO INSTALL MY OWN
CIRCUIT BREAKER."
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> NO, TRUST ME, THERE IS NO
GOD.
NOW, THE WHOLE IDEA OF A BREAKER
IS TO STOP A POWER SURGE, RIGHT?
SO, I THINK I SHOULD START WITH
THE POWER DIALED ALL THE WAY UP
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING
TO PROTECT MYSELF AGAINST,
RIGHT?
>> THAT IS VERY BAD LOGIC.
>> SO I GOT THIS THING CRANKED
UP HIGHER THAN LIGHTNING AND I'M
LIKE, "TIME TO SCREW IN THE
METAL SCREWS," RIGHT?
>> NO, NOT RIGHT.
>> CUT TO -- I FLY SO HARD
THROUGH A SHEET OF DRYWALL THAT
MY SCREAM PHYSICALLY DETACHES
FROM MY BODY AND TRAVELS AT A
SLOWER SPEED.
KIND OF LIKE PETER PAN'S SHADOW
DETACHING FROM HIS BODY.
>> YEAH, GOT IT.
>> SO AFTER I HIT A STEEL
SUPPORT COLUMN, WIPING OUT THE
ENTIRE FIRST FLOOR OF MY HOME, I
AM HIT IN THE FACE BY MY OWN
SCREAM.
WILD, RIGHT?
>> WOW.
AND WHAT DID YOU LEARN FROM ALL
OF THIS?
>> GLOVES.
YOU'VE GOT TO WEAR GLOVES.
>> WELL, THANK YOU, FELIX.
>> EXCITED TO GET MY CHECK.
>> THERE'S NO CHECK.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND OUR FINAL GUEST SAYS THAT
SHE'S BEEN TRYING TO REPAIR HER
HOME FOR MONTHS.
PLEASE WELCOME -- THIS CAN'T BE
RIGHT.
MY WIFE CARLISA.
♪♪
HEY, BABY.
UH, WHAT YOU DOING HERE?
>> JUST TRYING TO REPAIR MY
HOME.
THIS DAMN FOOL IS OUT HERE
PRETENDING HE'S A BIG EXPERT.
MEANWHILE, HIS OWN HOUSE IS
LITERALLY FALLING APART.
>> WELL, IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM,
BABY, I'M HAPPY TO FIX IT.
>> WITH WHAT?
THIS IS YOUR TOOLBOX.
BUT THERE AREN'T NO TOOLS IN
HERE, THOUGH.
IT'S JUST CANS OF BLACK'S BEER.
>> HEY, I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR
THOSE.
>> THERE'S NO TOOLS IN THIS
WHOLE GOOFY-ASS WORKSHOP.
IT'S JUST CHOCOLATE BARS THAT
LOOK LIKE TOOLS.
>> WELL, SOMETIMES I GET A
LITTLE HUNGRY.
>> MEANWHILE, OUR TOILET HASN'T
WORKED IN MONTHS.
I OPENED THE LID OF THE TANK AND
SAW THIS.
>> WELL, YOU NEVER KNOW WHEN YOU
MIGHT NEED AN ICE COLD HOT DOG.
>> AND THEN YOU SNUCK SOME
CRUSHED UP PEANUT SHELLS INTO
OUR SON'S LUNCH TO PROVE THAT HE
WAS FAKING HIS PEANUT ALLERGY.
>> WELL, THE IMPORTANT THING IS
THAT I TRUST YOU NOW.
I STILL THINK HE MAY BE
EXAGGERATING A LITTLE BIT.
>> GUS.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY FOR
YOURSELF?
>> LOOK.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT I
AM --
♪ IN OVER MY HEAD ♪
>> NO, NO, NO.
DON'T YOU DARE SING THAT DAMN
JINGLE TO ME, NO.
THIS MAN SUCKED UP A WASP NEST
WITH A VACUUM AND NOW HE WON'T
EVEN THROW IT AWAY.
>> LISTEN, DYSON --
>> IDIOT.
YOU'S AN IDIOT.
>> YOU WANT SOME OF THIS --
♪ OVER YOUR HEAD ♪♪